we just crossed a million sub so we
decided to go to drive tanks calm to
blow some stuff
[Music]
on the road two million subs we together
crushed some major milestones
now we have where I sit on a new target
three
the idea of a team has always been to
eliminate small thinking
dropped a bad habit of laziness
and help you overcome fear
wait a minute I don't recognize that
drawing should take care of it that's
more likely give me want to do it's time
to leave your mark as an entrepreneur
your minds a powerful weapon but it
needs the right spark you grew with us
you stay loyal to us you believed in us
so we're delivering on our promise it's
time for the first vitamin conference
[Music]